depuis quelques temps des sportifs de la
cobas s'était fixé pour devoir de
vacances dit acclimater le surfing nez
sur les plages d'hawaï
nous sommes en 1961 le surfing ou plus
simplement le surf n'en est qu'à ses
débuts en france
les planchistes se donne alors rendez
vous sur la côte basque
il est vrai que la plage idéale pour ce
sport new look c'est la plage de
biarritz comme vous pouvez en juger
des sports venue tout droit des
états-unis intrigue les journalistes non
ce n'est pas une planche à laver
[Musique]
ce n'est pas non plus une planche à
repasser malgré les apparences
pourtant le surf à droite très tôt à ses
premières compétitions officielles
comme à biarritz en 1961 muni d'une
large blanche
il s'agit de gagner la haute mer et de
la utilisant le mouvement des vagues de
partir à l'assaut du rivage
c'est ce qu'ont fait ou essayer de faire
à biarritz les concurrents du premier
championnat de france et d'europe 2 /
fing il faut dire que les plages du
sud-ouest offre des conditions optimales
pour surfer chaude les requins sont
absents les plages de sable est tendue
idéal pour découvrir ce nouveau loisir à
11h07 au tableau noir qu'on apprend les
trois positions clé un plat ventre sur
la planche pour gagner le large
accroupi et enfin debout pour le retour
sous la poussée de la vague
certains planchistes viennent même de
très loin pour ça ces itinérants
américains australiens sud africain
toujours à la recherche de la vague
le soft n'a pas de saison
au début des années 60 seuls quelques
téméraires pratiquer le surf
parmi eux joël de rosnay l'un des
pionniers du surf en france en 1967 il
racontait ses débuts dans ce sport je me
suis pas mal casser la figure au début
et puis ensuite ça a été un petit peu
mieux
et l'année suivante en 58 nous étions
déjà cinq ou six et en 59 une dizaine et
maintenant on peut dire que le nombre de
surfeurs double facilement tous les ans
plus de 60 ans après la découverte de ce
sport de glisse la biarritz
la fédération française de surf compte
environ 80 mille licenciés en 2020 le
surf s'apprête à franchir une nouvelle
étape pour la première fois il va
figurer au programme des jeux olympiques
de tokyo
[Musique]